on Monday Bugatti announced that one of
its cars a modified three million dollar
Chiron was clocked at over 300 miles per
hour on a test track in Germany and
that's the magic number the Bugatti and
two other car companies have been
chasing in the quest to build the
world's fastest production car but the
claim is controversial some car
enthusiasts say that if Bugattis
modified supercar is not sold to the
public as is did they really win the
race to 300 Don Dahler is gonna tell us
test driver Andy Wallace pushed the
specially modified bugatti chiron
to three hundred four point seven seven
miles an hour on Volkswagens five mile
long test track in Germany Volkswagen
owns Bugatti as well as fellow exotic
brands Lamborghini and benleah
immediately following the achievement
Bugattis president Steven we kiman
announced they're retiring from this
speed record business this work record
is for all of you however ladies and
gentlemen this was the very last time
for us but if the car was modified cam
Bugatti
really claimed they made the first
production vehicle to exceed 300 Road
and track editor-in-chief Travis a
Kolski says only if they start selling
this version of the sure on right now
Bugatti has not announced any plans to
build this car but you'd think that
they'd be real dumb if they didn't
because they'd be leaving a lot of money
on the table and possibly the actual
record for production cars the other
guys in the game say the race to the
record is still on last April we visited
one of them texas-based Hennessey
performance they're trying to make a
road legal everyday drivable production
car capable of 300 in response to
Bugattis record they tell us the car
bugatti tested is a prototype and not a
production spec car and thus does not
qualify as a true production car Swedish
supercar maker Koenig zeg which held the
previous speed record agrees we drove a
production version it was actually a
customer car kinegg shag is hoping to
make a run at the record within a year
and a car anyone with
say three million dollars you could buy
these cars are several million dollars
and people say oh you must make it ton
of money on each car actually no we have
normal profit margins on them but they
costs almost as much to make as we sell
them for these are the rarest of
creations made from the rarest of
materials carbon fiber and aviation
grade metals Christian von Koenigsegg
started the company from scratch in 1994
do you think the 300 is just this magic
round number that that gets people
excited because it seems absurdly fast
it is sub certainly fast and no one
should ever drive that fast on a public
road but it is kind of showing what's
possible but just knowing you have this
incredible machine with this huge
performance band this huge performance
envelope is exciting and it also shows
what modern technology is capable of is
it important to be the first well I
think it makes a bit of a difference
yeah for sure first - something is
always exciting as for the first
production car to go 300 Kinnick sag is
betting on the Jesco named after his
father who helped young christian barely
into his 20s go after a dream they got
totally shocked at the press conference
when we unveiled the car and was his
name on the car it was a very emotional
day for him and for me his tiny company
hit the big time this is the Koenigsegg
popular British car show Top Gear
vaulted the kunais egg from obscurity to
international fame when its CCX
set the track record it was like a
springboard for for bigger things and we
also notice it in our sales our customer
base grew and we could develop the cars
a little bit faster and take them to the
next level
and talk about the next level this is
the Ruggiero a 1,700 horsepower gas
electric hybrid that Kinnick seg says
can reach 280 miles an hour with a
single gear but you're not shifting no
just one gear yes one of Christians
inventions kennix egg will produce 30 of
these models a year in their Factory on
a retired Swedish Air Force Base they
use the old airstrip nearby as a test
track but it is the Jesco that will take
the company into the future and
hopefully the record books in comfort
and style
our goal was always to push the envelope
in all directions we also want to dakar
to be practical with a decent luggage
space it should be pretty roomy it
should be safe with air bags and have a
stereo we even have cupholders so in the
world of ridiculously expensive
ridiculously fast supercars just how
important are bragging rights a Kolski
of rodent tracks says vary the 300 mile
an hour goal is that the moonshot for
car companies it's their Apollo it is
the moment where they can say we've done
something no one else can do for CBS
this morning Saturday Don Dahler angle
home sweet yeah I can go 300 miles an
hour but it has a great luggage space
coffee it is amazing to think about